question let's read out the important
details okay ad is a vertical post ABAC
our roots of length three meters in form
is respectively
so far so good the rope AC this one the
quote that's closer to us is inclined at
30 degrees horizontal so that's an angle
of elevation ya calculate the height of
the post and the angle at which the rope
a B is inclined to the horizontal to the
nearest degree okay so because this is
the first question I think it's very
intentionally simple but there's still
some important lessons that I want to
draw out as we actually solve it okay so
the first thing to do is a tree tree
what does 3d treat encompass things that
you basically learn last year things
like writing the triangles right and
just the regular all ratios assigned
containing a right angle triangle it's
also going to incorporate sine and
cosine rule right so later on when we've
got triangles that are not right-angled
like some of these for instance if we
were to work out one of these sides we
would need to use one of these now apart
from that which is pretty stop standard
stuff from like your ten what does 3d
trick add in your eleven answer just
more trying goose that's all it is okay
so my tips for approaching these kinds
of questions just have to do with that
extra element to these questions okay so
tip number 103 tips number one is be
really clear about what you're after
okay so be clear about the unknowns you
have to solve alright so in this case I
reckon it's totally worth going out
getting some more like colored pencils
or something like that so that you can
draw out or draw your attention to which
elements here you after okay so if you
go back to the question I think what
they said is number one work out that
height okay so I often even put onto my
own diagram okay I put in another color
and mark
unknown that I'm trying to find and I
say okay it's question mark one of the
reasons why I do that is so that after
I've worked it out
I don't confuse myself as to what is
information that's given to me versus
what's the stuff that I've worked out
okay why it's the first thing what was
the second thing they wanted yeah that's
right so we've got this angle of
elevation ACD and they want the other
one
okay it's inclined to the horizontal so
there we go there's our first set up
number two my second tip is reverse it
all that that's different here is that
there are lots of triangles okay so how
do you make things clear up separate the
triangles out okay enjoy yourself a nice
2d diagram that'll show you if the
triangles that you're interested in and
then things are much clearer okay so for
instance if we try to work out the
height first which seems like the most
obvious thing because we have
information that triangle let's draw our
triangle ACD on its own okay
copy the information for and again
what's the unknown run off top okay
anything you unclear yeah yeah so now
this is what the reasons why 3d trick is
confusing to people just because it's
it's lots of triangles fit on top of
each other it's 3d that's not some
except the heading guys come on it isn't
some wacky that doesn't look like 90
degrees to me all right so now you can
see if this triangle is what I'm
interested in it becomes very clear what
kind of information you need to or what
kind of understanding you need to apply
to the question so what am I going to
use in this triangle I just was signed
right because I've got this angle I've
got the hypotenuse and I'm after the
opposite side okay so I would go so far
as to say in triangle ACD okay now this
is related to my third tip I'll just
finish this line first in a CD
sine of that angle equals opposites on
okay and use my third tip number three
be courteous with your working
what does cookies mean it's a great
old-fashioned word it means for every
single wine right make sure you put in
things like which triangle you're doing
which sides are actually free to don't
write things like pipe over for okay the
reason why is that having all of these
extra triangles it just makes it easier
to trip yourself up and forget which
side am I talking about and which ratio
and it just is very confusing okay so
it's my third tip yeah
I can't yeah good question take a seat
would you lose marks answer probably not
if you got the final answer right
however because it's so easy to you know
get your ratio upside down or I think
it's cause I said sign or tan or use the
cosine rule instead of just Ryan angle
tree you're sort of just doing yourself
in really so if this line is not there I
think you'll be okay you probably could
go straight to this line sign 30 equals
ad on for but the chance of you getting
that line wrong if you don't have any
prior working is much higher okay so
sign 30 is exactly it's a half so from
here I could say a equals to satisfy
that's okay all right great no there was
our first question what's the height so
I can say now right so let's just move
on to the next bit because it's in
another triangle again I'm gonna draw it
the second time so this is um this is
tip number two right so let's draw abd
three two this is the angle I'm off top
okay
so again it's clear what am I going to
use finding the triangle we trace sure
it's signed a game okay partly because
the information they're asking for is so
closely related to the other information
that we already have okay so you know
the triangles it might have required tan
or clause or whatever but in this case
same one so I would say in this triangle
abd sign of abd is equal to opposite on
my partner's so probably a next line of
the ok2say abd is sine inverse on two
three
then whip out your calculator and off
you go okay what is that by the way I
think they what do they want noose
degree on ears minute nearest degree
make sure in the right mode
only 42 degrees yeah 41.8 yes no yes
thank you 42 degrees
okay nothing to - okay so I picked out a
simple example just so we can focus on
what the tips are as questions get
harder what are the differences okay
they'll start to add in more times
they're not right-angled so you have to
go to more complicated rules okay and
also you'll have to work out you know
for instance when you have to work out
the height it was very direct okay they
were no intermediate lengths in to
calculate okay but later on for instance
I might we'll ask you to calculate what
to BC about which we know much less as a
triangle okay I'm not even sure if you
have enough information here maybe you
do but you see my point right is that
here it's very direct there's a triangle
everything is set up almost okay later
on you'll have to do this triangle and
then another one to actually get the
length or the magnitude game